[Music]
hello everyone this is gm joshua
and today i'll be doing gm choice
which is my favorite lecture because i
can choose anything i want which works
out pretty well
i decided to choose a game that i
saw from the
fide grand prix which is currently going
on in berlin
and it was a game between richard raport
and vladimir ferozeev
a really fascinating game and i kind of
just like choosing games which i find
very interesting to go over
you can approach it from two angles when
you prepare lectures basically you can
approach it from all right this is going
to be extremely educational for these
purposes and you show it or you can
basically go
this looks just like fun so let me show
this
and i think this falls into the second
category a bit more but there are still
plenty of things we can learn from this
game
a reminder also that
i am reading the youtube chat
so if i asked questions or have you guys
say things i will
be seeing those
uh i will be seeing your comments on
youtube so without further ado
it was a nimzo indian one of my favorite
openings kind of for both colors it's
just a very rich opening with lots of
different structures
and i find that it doesn't really get
too boring hey davina how's it going
queen c2
castles a3
bishop takes c3 check queen takes c3
b6
so very very
standard um
very very standard nimzo indian i would
say that
at least from personal tastes i always
found these queen c2 lines to be almost
obnoxious
because it's already moved seven and you
haven't developed any of your minor
pieces apart from the knight which got
captured and all of this just to capture
the two bishops and keep your pawn
structure nice and pretty without taking
with the b-pawn
i always found it to be
again slightly obnoxious but at the same
time of course it's a personal opinion
obviously it's fine for white right
but it's more that's
white has to be very careful because
they are behind the development so it's
one thing that you've taken the two
bishops but you have to be very careful
with how you proceed from here
so white plays bishop g5 which is
typical
bishop e7
and i would say that
uh james commented that report is a wild
man that's absolutely true but one of
the things i've noticed is that he used
to be regularly rated around
2700
and in fact when he beat up on me that's
about what his rating was
but at that time
he was he would play all sorts of random
openings he'd get dead lost positions
against 2400s against me he actually
blitzed out like 20 moves of theory i
felt cheated in a sense
but
he would get all these awful positions
and come back
and one of the things i've noticed in
the last year or year and a half maybe
two years is that all of a sudden he's
playing slightly more mainstream theory
but with a twist
and all of a sudden his rating is almost
27.70 and i don't think that's an
accident
so i think he's one of the very best
players in the world right now and one
of the reasons is because he learned how
to play openings not some huge opening
expert but just decent openings that
surprise people
and
he kind of goes from there he also is
not really picky about trying to choose
the most popular line so for example in
this position the most popular move is
f3
and then after h6 bishop h4 d5 this is a
whole big line
so one of the main features here is that
if white takes immediately you actually
take with the e pawn with the idea that
after e3 rook e8 this pressure on the e3
pawn is quite annoying
so typically white plays e3 first knight
bd7 and now takes and you get this end
game
which has been around for centuries okay
centuries might be an exaggeration but
it's been around a long time
and the whole idea is that if you take
on c7 i go here and i'm forking these
two
jigs and that's very very annoying for
whites
so you don't really want your center to
get decimated especially when you're
behind the development which still
matters in an end game so white usually
goes back nega back to d5 bishop f2 and
then black wants to open the position
not because white has the two bishops
obviously bishops love open positions
but because black's ahead in development
so even though it's an end game black's
lead in development tends to go well
and again it's all theoretical and
there's still playable options for both
colors i think black's considered okay
but
i'm not exactly an expert in that line i
i usually play slightly differently as
black myself
and then there's e3 as a move and then
you can play d6 usually knight bd7 and
white can play knight f3 or knight e2 or
almost anything even f3 here is a move
so there's endless options there really
are
report chooses knight h3
and this is the kind of move that
you feel like any normal master would
yell at their student for playing a move
like this
and the fact is that
it's very important to learn not to put
knights in the edge first so say if
you're rated 1200 and you're looking at
this game don't play moves like this
just put your pieces in the center get
castled okay keep your life simple
but once you learn about structures more
you realize that the knight on h3
actually makes a fair amount of sense
and one of the reasons is that first of
all it defends this bishop which can be
somewhat useful
but also white wants to be playing with
f3 e4 someday
and
the knight often will slide back to f2
where it's quite useful and the reason
why white goes for f3
f3 also i should mention looks like a
weird move you're behind the development
just get your pieces out
but the whole point of f3 is that it
dulls both the bishop and the knight
it makes both of these pieces worse
which is why you can get away with a
move like this
so a knight three is kind of a clever
attempt to say well maybe i'll play e3
maybe i'll play f3
i'm holding on to my bishop just a way
to kind of make life more interesting
so black plays h6
and plays d6 here
so i don't know in my view
the most testing
of the most testing move here should be
d5 trying to play in the center
and the idea is that after takes e takes
e3 for instance one advantage that this
has for white is that your pawn
structure is like this meaning that
moves like rookie 8 don't do as much
because e3 is defended
but black can play c5 and then the idea
is to play knight c6 and target this
d-pawn which can't be defended as well
because the knights committed here
so the basic i'm not really trying to
teach you guys theory so much but it's
more about
why each opening move
exists for that reason and each opening
move kind of has a slight defect to it
so the knight on h3 can't control the d4
square as well
the pawn and f3 lets go of e3 a little
bit so there's always something and
there's a reason why usually there are
lots of options and no clear best move
black can also think about playing c5
which is its own kind of mess
but i do want to get into this game
because it is quite interesting i just
want to show a few things about the
opening so d6 was played
report plays f3 knight bd7 e4
and now c5 a very typical thing black
has a very solid setup here but it's
also a bit passive and if you allow
white to just build and castle
eventually they build an attack this is
not something you'd like so much
so you have to try to counter the center
in some way
so report ignores this
and this i think is an interesting
moment because black has lots of
different options to improve they can
play queen e7 is is a possible move but
the problem is that it walks into e5 so
queen e7 would be a normal move it
doesn't work as well here i don't
believe
rookie 8 is a move which was played in
the game and rook c8
personally i kind of like rook c8
the main reason for this is that you're
you're kind of aiming up the rook with
the queen but there's also a very
concrete purpose which let's say this
happens and i take c5 and this could
have happened in the game by the way
so if white tries to take everything
which again was very much like the game
and played b4
the rook on c8 is a lot more active than
the rook on e8 so you can play something
like knight b3
rook d1 to prevent the knight from going
to d4 and then d5 and because the rook
is open on the c file you're going to
have lots and lots of counter play here
so even though your pawn structure has
been a little bit messed up you still
have a development lead because white's
not castled yet white doesn't have a
nice safe king their rook on h1 can't
play so i think that this position would
offer black more chances personally
in the game he played rook e8 and it
gets pretty similar he takes
so here i'd actually recommend taking
with the pawn because i think that
trying to take with the knight is a
little bit ambitious here because those
lines don't work out as well so i think
taking with the pawns a bit better and
then after castle's queen side queen b6
life kind of continues honestly like the
game is very unclear i would say though
that d5 is coming so probably white has
to do something interesting like maybe
sacrifice a pawn this way
the idea being that after knight takes
bishop takes the the these pawns are
really terrible with the king on g8 in
the middle game
so you probably should actually take
with the pawn and now just a move like
bishop d3 and black's position is
actually weird because it blacks up a
pun but their pieces have trouble moving
so and eventually white will maybe try
to attack with something like this i
don't know so i feel this position is is
quite unclear
but the move knight takes c5 happened
and again it looks reasonable but i
think with the rook on e8 is just not
really as good
report goes for this end game and often
this end game is kind of not much
like usually black brings the king in
brings the rooks to the center it feels
fine
but white can immediately play b4 and
force the knight back which is a problem
and now the variations actually get
quite interesting knight b3 was played
knight d7 actually might be slightly
better with the idea of trying to play
rook c895 and target the c pawn
he was likely worried about something
like castles and now this pawn is not
defensible again if black had time to do
this
not kd6 but king e7 black would probably
just be completely fine
but they don't actually have time so
they go for something like knight e5
rook takes d6 and here black has a nice
tactic with rook takes knight takes c4
but even here it's not over this is
actually quite interesting you have
bishop takes c4
and here
black actually can play
both rooks here
and i guess i'll ask you guys a question
which rook do you think would be better
so again on youtube feel free to shout
out and again for a move like this
having reasons is nice if you say rook
ac8 that's nice but like why is rook ac8
better
all right i see 1a rook one e-rook
2a rooks all right a-rooks are winning
do the a-rocks have it
f-rook oh my goodness that doesn't even
exist
get two more e-rooks okay
so yeah there are things like well the
kingside rook already has moved but i
would tell you that those kind of that
kind of thinking can get you into
trouble because sometimes you have to
move a piece a bunch of times it's just
the way chess works so it's really about
which rook either serves more of a
purpose purpose not a purpose or is less
in the way
and it turns out that the e-rook
is not very well placed
after rook ac8
white can play rook d4
and this is actually very annoying it
looks like this move doesn't do any good
because black will play here
but now you play rook's d7 and there's a
very very big problem
if you play first of all if you take the
bishop immediately i play king b2
rook c8 and the easiest for white is
actually just a take
allow this check takes this knight
takes here
and the whole point is that white has a
much better king you'll notice that
black's king on g8 is just kind of
sitting there
and does nothing while the white king is
just marching up the board so this kind
of position actually is very very bad
for black in my opinion
so the natural move would be something
like this but here white has a very very
nice move
rook d4 is to to provoke the move e5 so
that rook d7 carries a bit more weight
it also means that like it's not
possible for black to just play bishop
c6 for example because there's always
bishop takes up seven check ideas and
things like this
so it's basically to to provoke the move
e5
uh but why does this not work what move
does white have here which is quite
strong
uh b5 doesn't actually help you very
much because i think i can take it
due to the pin
oops
think about the rook on e8 in ways in
which that piece might not be so strong
very nice
and the fact that this hits f6 with
tempo is actually a very big problem
because after rip takes c4 check king b1
you don't want to go to b2 because it
allows rook c8 and then there's rook c2
check so b1 is actually important
and now you have to take time to play
the move king g7
and now when you take this pawn the
bishop has to move back you play knight
e3
the knight can go to d5 you just are up
a pawn with a really great position
so it looks like rookie c8 rook ac8
sorry is the more logical move but
because knight g4 is such an important
tempo on the f-pawn
it actually doesn't work as well
so rook ec8 is actually the better move
so now if rook d4 for example
e5 rook d7 there's another perk which is
that after bishop a6 rook the a7 pawn
doesn't hang
so that's another very big advantage so
this kind of thing would actually be
fine for black
so king b2
rook takes c4
knight g4 so you go for this anyway but
here you don't have to defend against
knight takes f6 so clearly because
it doesn't like win a rook or anything
so you can actually just activate your
own rook
and i don't think white should actually
take this pun because i think allowing
rook c2 with both rooks and the bishop
is too dangerous
so probably you go back here rook c3 and
then just rookie one i definitely think
white's still better i think that this
bishop is not that great right now and
rook d7 is always in the air so you have
to maybe try like rook c7 someday or
something and eventually white can just
try to build on the queen king side
maybe
and the white king also has more
potential
but i definitely think black's kind of
in the game here
instead
uh that may have been possible let me
check so after rook d4
ah sorry sorry sorry i in the line with
rook a
see it's so rook d4
so if you play b5 i think again i have
knight g4
and this tempo is just super annoying
for you
and the whole idea is if you play a move
like say king g7 now i can play knight
e3
and then i probably will just gang up on
the c pawn or maybe just play rook d7
here and it feels like black's very
passive
uh this position probably does not look
very good
so
uh again i haven't looked at every
single line right but it's a reasonable
question so thank you for asking
so in the game black played knight b3
rook d1a5
and here life gets very very complicated
already report has to make very very
difficult decisions so here he has to
choose between capturing this pun or
playing rook d3 trying to go after this
knight or at least make the knight worse
so which move do you think you guys
would go for rook d3 or rook takes d6
these are your options
of course if you think you see a better
move go ahead but i really feel like
you kind of want to choose one of those
moves because otherwise
black's just going to take and bring the
rook in and you're going to feel kind of
sad also d5 could become a move i don't
know
so the idea of a5 is basically to help
save this knight otherwise moves like
rook d3 are just gonna win the night
someday
so rook takes d6 is what was played in
the game uh the question is is it the
better move like which which move do you
prefer
i actually think the choice is not easy
at all so i'm kind of curious
i bet you you put this position in front
of several gm's they're all going to
choose different ones
so i think if after rook d3
white black had to move the knight
report would have played this move for
sure or if they have to play a4 taking
the pressure off and making this rook
less active for sure he would have
played this
but i'm pretty sure the move he was
afraid of was atex beef
blur so you can actually take this pawn
back but then moves like rook a one
check come into the play
but i actually think you can think about
rook takes b3
and the whole point is that now b takes
a3
rook b1
a2 rook a1
and black's down a piece but they have
an awful lot of counter play especially
with that a pawn and white's still not
developed just because it's an end game
doesn't mean you don't develop right
so a move like d5 could be problematic
i still think though this would be
pretty good for white the key though is
that you have to find a way to get your
pieces out so i actually very much like
this move king d2 just trying to get the
king over
and again it's very complicated i don't
know
how clear it is but i definitely think
white's on top here
in the game he actually went with rook
takes d6 instead
so rook takes d6 is definitely
quite a reasonable option
so his opponent took
played rook a one check and now once
again you have a very very difficult
choice in my view
and that is whether you play knight d1
or rook d1
and this is just to show you how
difficult this position was to play i
mean
these are not easy choices to make they
both have very severe drawbacks
so i guess first of all before you
start to discuss which move you like
like what are the potential
pluses and minuses of rook d1 and of
knight d1
so it's been pointed out that knight d1
allows king f2 this is absolutely true
that's a very nice perk of knight d1
that it allows the king a nice escape
route the king wants to get out of dodge
here the king on e1 is not very good
even in the end game king position can
really be a problem so i think that's a
big
plus anything else
there's another perk of knight d1 which
i feel like should be mentioned
well eventually a king march might be a
very nice idea but
we've talked about that already so
knight d1 does allow king f2 what's
another perk of knight d1 that's more
straightforward it's to do with this
rook
keep in mind that the knight really
can't go anywhere for now like it's
going to be pinned for a while most
likely so
yeah this is definitely one so knight d1
allows rook takes b6
and it allows king f2
a potential drawback though is that the
knight doesn't defend the center as well
from d1 and you're also you are walking
into a pin right
so it's really difficult decision to
make obviously it's not just about
concepts right you have to do the
concepts but you also have to calculate
what happens
everything is very concrete when the
position becomes very complicated so i
would say that it's nice to have a grasp
of what the concepts are sometimes you
can figure out well i just want to keep
my rook active and that's more important
and things like this
but ultimately you have to calculate so
the fact that the knight is pulled off
of this e4 pawn
allows black to play the idea f5
so we still get to take on b6
bishop a8 but now our pawn our center is
kind of getting under attack and if the
center opens that can be very bad for
our knight
so we play e5
and the idea is now that if rook d8
trying to target our knight we can play
rook d6 always
but the game is actually not over yet
black has a really great resource here
and i'm curious if you guys can find it
finding resources for your opponent that
are that is very strong
is like a great skill to develop because
it helps you spot a lot of different
things
so what can black try here
their bishop's kind of out of the game
they have this night pinned but they
can't really do much
very good whoopster f6
and white actually has no great response
to this if they take the pawn
then rook d1 and there's a very big
problem with this d1 knight
so if bishop e2 knight d4 all of a
sudden white actually has some big
problems to solve
i don't recommend that
you can play a move like f4 but that
really opens up this bishop and that
gives black
loads of extra options so that's clearly
not something you want either
so i think the best course of action is
to ignore it with something like b2
and this isn't the only option for black
but taking the pawn makes sense to me
king f2
and now play could go something like
knight d4 rookie 1
rook a2 knight c3
rook b2 just trying to keep pressure up
here
and now just king f1 just dropping back
to make sure my pieces can move
and if e4 trying to open things f4
keeping things closed
i still like white but i would say that
this position is complete
mess like this is not easy to play and
of course the players have to kind of
try to figure all this stuff out it's
easier after the game when you can pause
and think for a long time come check
with the computer and stuff like that
then things become more
a bit easier to figure out but i would
say that just in general
the amount of resources that are
possible in a position this rich is
quite something
so i can assure you that the players
were not underestimating what was here
so richty one was played
uh federer plays the very logical move
rook ea8
so here there was a possibility of
bishop d3 or bishop e2 he chose bishop
b2 i kind of like bishop d3 better
but it's also very complicated uh the
main thing i'm going for here though is
to complete my development and have
everything defended
i feel like the bishop on e2 sometimes
comes under more fire with a rook on a2
so one possibility here is that here you
have to take with the the knight i
believe
rook a4 you play b5
and it's weird because you've given up
this square
but this bishop is also completely
worthless
so for me this is a bit of a mixed bag
like the knight on c5 could be annoying
a move like this i think is playable
i don't know
overall i'd say that allowing this
is not so easy to do
in the game he played bishop e2 and this
is where things got really crazy
uh you thought they were crazy so far
but no ferasev plays knight c1
and this is kind of the fun thing it's a
crazy position to begin with so no
matter who's playing it's going to be
fun but i would say both report and
fedexiv are players known for their
creativity so you're going to see a lot
of fun stuff
and trust me guys it's just beginning
so
what can he do right this knight on c1
but there's no immediate threat so
report plays knight g4
rook 8 a2 so i don't know here i was
getting nervous for whites
the only reason why white's not dead
lost is because this bishop still can't
get into the game
if that bishop ever gets into the game
white's probably done
so but it's not so easy to actually do
so report
grabs this pun with check
which looks brave but is absolutely the
correct decision in my view
and here
ferocious at least in my view had a very
tricky decision on what to play here
between king g7 hitting the knight
trying to gain that tempo
or king f8
which one do you think you guys would do
i think he chose correctly in the game
but
it's of course very complicated
yeah i mean king f8 is is what was um
is what was played and and that's the
main
advantage
oh man i'm getting asked why i'm wearing
a mask just not in english now it's
getting really crazy all right uh so
uh yeah so it looks weird to play king
of fate to me at first because if you
allow like e5 rook d8 you're gonna get
mated but this bishop is hanging with
check and there's not so much you can do
about that so easily
king g7 was definitely possible
but as was pointed out
knight h5 check king g6 knight f4
uh
king g5 at first i thought this was
actually very tricky because the knight
is going to get hit next move
but white has a very very cool move here
yeah like what do you do i mean like i
understand that
the you know the knights back on f4
defending stuff but at the same time
that king is kind of going for a ride
here
h4 it would be nice but after king takes
knight i don't think you actually
checkmate me i think you're going to get
checkmated yourself
more likely
g3 is not a bad move but i think there's
a stronger one
like after g3 there's still e5 moves to
contend with and stuff like that
knight h39 g1 would be quite something
wow i have to just put this on the board
knight g1 this is definitely a way to go
i feel like though you're asking for
huge amounts of trouble apart from just
what happens if black
lets your knight be terrible and just
like improves a piece or something i
think something like this could prove to
be problematic
oh no no i'm sorry the the rooks defend
each other this was this is an example
of how to lose as as black but
but i don't know like if i just play
king e5 i don't actually know what
you're going to do like here maybe
even just knight takes e2 doesn't look
oh no i don't want to take
maybe f5 or something
i'm not sure like it's still very
difficult to move
the idea though is actually a good one
but you should not play put your knight
on g1 first you should play king f2
right away
and this move is kind of amazing because
you're just going to take this knight
right so it's very very difficult for
for black to do anything here
so they probably have to defend it and
now you can play king e3 for example
if rook a3 check you just play bishop d3
there's no follow-up
and after e5
you can play knight check
and bishop d3 and everything's covered
everything's defended there's no checks
this pin is really annoying so after
rook c3 now you can draw back
everything's nice everything's clear you
have your extra pawn this bishop is not
very good
so i think this would be good for white
but this was this is obviously like very
very difficult
um and the cool thing is after takes you
have a cool trick you play takes so the
rooks are interacting
rook takes rook and now you have knight
h3 check to make sure there's no knight
takes knight and then you take the rook
and this knight is
like why it's just up in exchange and
upon coupons for nothing
so king g7 looks adventurous but
actually helps white so he plays king f8
instead
and here
he go report decides to go
on an adventure
uh he didn't have to
i think that there was actually a
stronger move
her dear jumps into a convenience store
that's funny
i have to say from i mean i
like grew up in new hampshire so there's
a fair amount of deer like not a crazy
amount but
they're not the smartest of animals uh i
will tell you they're not as dumb as
moose for sure
but they do some dumb things i i must
say
probably you're not supposed to like you
know talk about the intelligence of
animals when you're doing a chess video
but you know we're here it's fine it's
my last week i'm not going to get fired
for it right this is the key you do it
on your last week you engage in
controversy
but seriously like what would you guys
do as whitehead like
i'm curious like
how many of you would go on an adventure
how many of you try to play defend it's
it's a very tricky situation
because the the funny thing about this
move is that
like i don't think it's best but you
know but i can totally see why he played
it and i think it's very likely i would
have tried it myself
f3
yes
yes once f3 has been played it's it's
all over there's no way to improve your
position right
uh report did in fact play king of two
and just pitch the bishop and said ah
whatever i'm getting out of here
yeah we got to do like a bet for the
number of mask questions per video
and then like you know the winner gets
something i feel like this this would be
a great contribution
oh deleted look at that boom
and so you guys know i'm not gasping for
air i'm doing just fine
it is fashionable it's been pointed out
to me that the more of my face i cover
the better looking i am so
just i'm going for it
anyway guys can you so king of two again
is oop that's not how king f2 works
he's shy man everyone's giving me a hard
time today it's brutal so king f2 is
what report played which is a really
interesting move and not a bad one but i
think there was something a bit stronger
so see if you guys can find it
you guys are like what we're looking at
chester what's going on
i thought we're talking about mask
fashion or something
nothing my goodness
the thing is this move is actually like
there aren't that many moves for white
that don't lose on the spot so you it
doesn't give you a huge range of options
king h8 for black would be quite a
provocative move i must say
but maybe it's possible
so e5 does threaten rook d8 and mate
the problem you have here is that
you're
like you're not going to be able to
force that move in so easily
so one problem might simply be just
knight takes bishop because if you
you're pinned now you can't play rook d8
check if i try to do it leeches won't
let me it's kind of annoying
so if and if takes takes and you skewer
the the piece right
so knight takes e2 is probably just a
very simple
pro knight takes e2 is probably a very
simple problem e5 is very tempting i can
understand why you do it
but
and so you know if you play like takes
king f2 i can probably just take
check here take this rook and that's not
going to be a whole lot of fun
so i don't recommend e5
you can play 97 check but after king e7
i don't know that you've improved your
position either
it's a very simple move guys
don't try to look for anything too crazy
report already took care of that for us
but i have a feeling he thought that
this move was just too passive and that
something bad would happen maybe he saw
something very specific
yeah andreas very nice uh bishop f1
is basically the only move left
but what's amazing about this is that
there's not really
there's not really anything black can do
that's so effective
so for example the line i have here
again obviously this was with some
computer help but the fact is that like
knight d3 check or this move
bishop c8 it does prevent knight d7
which is very nice
and it's threatening here so white just
shuts them down with e5 and black almost
has no moves like white can just kind of
improve at will now
so probably black will grab an exchange
with check
takes rook takes d1
rogue takes h1 h3
but i actually think this position is
extremely bad for black white's going to
play here this bishop is going to be
basically a dead piece
and white can outmaneuver black at will
slowly start pushing the queen side and
i think that black is probably going to
be losing here i would say either lost
or very close to lost
and it's mainly because this bishop can
never ever play
so when you're playing down a piece it's
usually not a good thing and here i
think it's not an exception
so i i definitely think this wasn't so
simple uh and you have to really
realize like how difficult this is but i
think this exchange sack is very good
for white
but it could also be on he just rejected
bishop f1 because let me put it this way
i understand his decision very well
because bishop f1 looks so passive that
oh man like what am i gonna do after
this move whereas king f2 it's like at
least i'm doing something
and to be fair to him this is not a bad
move i think white still has a decent
position but black does have more
chances now
so his idea is basically look i'm out of
here
rook takes c2 king g3
he's just like peace i'm gone
and it's actually pretty effective
rook c2
and the question is what does he do now
this is another very important move that
he plays a really nice move
um
so
so i think e5 you have to watch out
because i can play knight e2 check
and then i have rook takes c4 with check
quite often i could also think about
just taking
yeah knight here and then the problem is
i'm gonna take everything with check
you're not gonna get an opportunity to
checkmate me with rook d8 i don't think
so i don't think that worked quite as
well
so he plays king h4 this is just a
beautiful move
he's basically like look my king is an
attacking piece and i'm going to use it
and this is a really nice
uh
idea
one of the things i would say that gets
underestimated a lot is this kind of
king run in an end game
and there's apart from it just being
objectively a good move i think it's
also very annoying to deal with
practically it's easy to try to play
against an opponent's king when they're
kind of a sitting duck or they're not
active it's much easier to play when all
of a sudden their king starts running
wreaking havoc
and running all over the board screaming
it's just very annoying to deal with
like how do you deal with a stupid king
it's just going to keep moving up
so for example after rook takes c4
white can just play here
and what is black doing like how do you
stop this this this king from just
ravaging you um for example if here i
can simply check here
and now you either have to let me take
this pawn someday walk into this fork
actually this knight d6 fork is the main
problem so like for example if
king f8 i can play knight d6
and this is a big problem
so
rook c2 i think is a better try
but here i can simply take this
rook g2 e5 so i'm threatening this
you have to go back
i take this knight
and black could take here and apparently
this position is unclear
but i was kind of surprised like my
initial reaction is oh this has to be
great for white like look at our king
look at how passive they are apparently
computer is not that impressed
but i feel like for a human being this
position is pretty good like i think for
most of us we'll
we'll find our way to do be okay here
for for white but apparently it's still
quite unclear
so this would have been the best try but
not so easy for any human being to play
and that's kind of what i mean when
you're dealing with this king running up
the board
waving his arms like a madman it's just
very difficult to actually deal with
so in the game he played this which is a
very logical move
so here actually reporter could have
played knight check
and knight d6 and this is very boring
but it's also very strong because this
knight is now not very good
and sorry this bishop is now not very
good so for example if it goes it
probably should just go to a8 we can
always just play b5 at some point and
like this bishop is just stuck and black
has no moves so eventually white just
improves their pawns
so this would be actually quite good for
white
in the game we played knight h5 check
which i think is a bit less strong
and here the this is one of my favorite
lines so in the game he played king g6
which is actually quite a bad blunder
although the reasons for it are quite
complex
so he play king f8 i think is a better
move making sure this king stays safe
it's funny like one of the toughest
calls to make in these positions is
knowing when you should get adventurous
with your king and this was a pretty
good adventure overall
and knowing when you should not get
adventurous and i'd say black's king
because there are so many potential
mating threats should not get
adventurous at all black's kings would
say nice and calm
white's king getting adventurous though
makes sense
so check
rook d1 so this looks like oh man rook
d7 is coming this is just juicy
but of course black has a very nice
defensive resource here
ah
and these lines get real fun
uh well e5 i don't think is going to
save you i can play
check and probably take your bishop
uh but i can probably also checkmate you
right like there has to be a mate here i
refuse to believe
check in here perhaps
i guess there's bishop c8 though that's
annoying
oh wait even here i can try to meet you
check
takes takes threatening mates
ah you have this
maybe i don't care ah rook f4
okay i got two adventures i'm sorry this
is what happens when i don't prepare
uh but okay i can at the very least just
take your bishop right like this this
should be winning pretty easily
bishop d5 very good
cutting off communication
but of course we're not nearly done
we're nowhere near completed we play
rook b8s
best move
now once again only one move for black
very good avinash rook 8 bishop still
defending the rook
tactics check out so we take bishop
takes
rook check
king f8
and here believe it or not white has to
try to draw we're down a piece
and a move like this i think runs into
this and then this is the key our bishop
defends
so white actually has only one way to
draw here
but it is quite a nice one
keep in mind that sometimes you're down
a piece you gotta
you gotta cash in
not cash in but
and i don't know where you mean cashing
in with the bishop like i think that
black really didn't have any need to try
to
i don't think black needed to cash in
anywhere like he's kind of staying up a
piece yeah
e5 is possible
but it does look slow so it does give me
a tempo to try to deal with this maybe
the simplest way or no bishop d3 that's
a lot of material
maybe just oh i can't go back why is
that annoying ah maybe here
because now the rook probably has to
move again and then you go here and then
the bishop kind of can go back if it
needs to
maybe that's a problem
i'm not sure
yeah you can play rectax f7 check very
good andreas
takes check you can't go to g6 because
you get mated embarrassingly you have to
go back and then here and you can't stop
this perpetual
without giving up way too much material
pretty cool huh
so that's how this game could have gone
in fact if black had played it well
but yeah quite something um
so king g6 was played and report plays
rook d8 obvious enough
playing for mate
rook back
rook hd1
takes c4
report takes and plays here
and then this was the moment where
i think they calculated different lines
and i think reports saw a bit more
and again it could have been time
pressure this was such a crazy game i
mean
to play this game on no time
uh is very
difficult so
ferocious took on e4
maybe the best try was to play king h7
but after rook takes a8 knight d3 for
example you have to try to like prevent
e5
uh obvious e5 is not possible yet but it
would have been possible if you take
this pun
rook a7 king g6 rook d7 is very annoying
dislodging this knight so if something
like knight takes b4
you play rook d8 again threatening this
king h7 and now the move f4 and this is
so nasty
because you can't take this pawn due to
knight f6 and i'm just gonna march my
pawn up the board and then checkmate you
with knight f6 and rook g8 and you can't
really stop it effectively it's very
annoying
uh so the king can be such a important
piece in the end game so like rook c6 i
thought was a decent try
but now i play rook f8 hitting the pun
and g4 and once again
either this is coming or g5 more likely
and it's very sad you just get mated
so quite something
and just to show you an example of how
it could happen uh let's say i play like
knight back to d3 for example
uh i don't know what the most accurate
move order probably is just oh no check
allows this
so i should not do that probably just g5
and now i'm threatening check and meat
and if i take then i just simply take
with the pun and once again threatening
check and mate
and if you ever try to move this then i
have all sorts of options but the
simplest is just to take and this pawn
is so good
that you're probably just gonna do this
and mop up and
black is in no way
able to fight against any of this
so just as an example of how things can
go down also i should point out king
takes pawn is also very possible here
and may even be just as strong so
having a good king is important in the
end game that's the conclusion
in the game though he played bishop
takes e4 which clearly he counted on
so the question is
what does report do here and i think
this is where again he just calculated
this part a little bit better than fedex
did
of course could have not gone down that
way but that's my suspicion
so i think if you do that it's actually
not so great avinash because after czech
and g4 king here i think you're actually
forcing my king where it wants to go my
king wants to escape this way
and you don't quite have time to
checkmate me so i actually think this
makes black's life better not worse
f4 i think you're threatening mate but i
don't think i have to allow mate
um
let me see what i would do
it's possible i would just sack a piece
back maybe something like this so you
can check and take this bishop but then
i take this pawn and i don't think this
has gone well for you either my king is
actually a lot safer now
um
yeah i'm sorry
uh yeah and anyway don't be sorry about
wrong suggestions that's part of why we
do this right so
uh and a lot of the times what i would
say is that like several people
suggested your line so
it's like if one of us like for example
if one of you suggests a line that maybe
didn't work probably other people
thought it worked too
so it's always good to to suggest these
things we all learn stuff and as you
know sometimes you suggest something and
i have no idea why it doesn't work or
maybe it does work you know i
i try to prepare these lectures as well
but there are definitely things i miss
e5 might have saved as well i didn't see
the i don't remember exactly but
white has a really great move here
though uh and i believe andreas found it
g4
this is what report played and it's an
amazing move
if rook g8 you're threatening to mate
with knight f6 and after f5 you can play
rook d7 and then this mate is
unstoppable as well
after takes you simply take back and
game over
but of course fedex fought on he found
one move to stay in the game that move
is king
h7 ah
and now that report takes it's so much
better like keep in mind he could have
taken on e4 right away
but now after rook takes e4 check
f5 you don't have time for rook d7
because this hangs with check so you
have to play h3 and then after takes
takes king f7
i mean this is not a clear position at
all in my opinion um
like after a check of course after
knight f6 probably white should draw but
it's definitely not
not that easy right like this is not
what you want
so
g4 was a really nice move and then takes
and here he should win easily enough
if the problem is if rook takes b4 you
play e5 and you're still mating him
you haven't actually solved the mating
net issue
so ferocious finds the only tri which is
knight
e5 uh and that's a good point suzanne
that the knight on c1 is definitely poor
and that contributes to this if the
knight on c1 were in the game
this would be probably a lot easier for
black
so having a bad piece even though it was
an extra piece for a while
was not so great
so here he could do he could win in
several ways he chooses knight f6 check
and rook d6
which i definitely think is perfectly
reasonable
92
and here he basically just wants this
knight to get to a good square
so how would you reposition this knight
huh that is funny james
rook takes b6 is probably good enough i
don't think there's anything wrong with
the move
um he actually chooses knight g8
and the purpose of this is that now
after king g7 he takes this pawn and the
knight's ready to head to f5 where it's
going to be very very strong
so his repositioning of the knight is
nice and he also is improving like he's
also taking a pawn while he does it
right
so here rook takes e4 was played
knight f5 check king h7
rook takes our rook h6 check first sorry
rook takes b6 knight f4
and of course
what would the game be if he doesn't
activate his king even further
king g5
and this is actually a problem because
like he's still trying to mate black
which is quite funny
like this king is still coming up and
you still have to worry about getting
mated so it makes defense of this
endgame where you're down a pawn even
more difficult
so fidoseiv actually decides to play
uh to play f6 check which is a kind of a
clever idea
so how does report respond to this move
first of all
and i must say this part of the game was
calculated very well because this is
like
not the easiest thing in the world i
would say it's harder to play black than
white but
very good susan king h6 is definitely
best if you take and allow rook takes b4
the game's simplified a bit
it's probably still winning i would
guess but it's a little more complicated
maybe also this check could be a
possibility because you can't go to g6
which is where you want to go because of
this
or wait no no this actually just wins
probably
that might actually mate you have to
play rook four or something and
okay then i can just push
yeah okay this is this is
knight h3 check was not good but you can
probably take if king h6 now you can
always go back to not get mated at least
or wait does this even work
ah you have check
it's always something right like it's
never so easy but in general king h6 is
nice because you keep your
past pawn over here
and you're ready to start advancing so
after rookie two he plays h4
king f7 rook b5
rook p2 rook b8 so he's basically just
making this pawn dangerous and then
he'll try to win over here somehow
knight d5
h5
e4 so finish it's getting some counter
play but it's a bit too little too late
and report simply takes this pawn right
like
it looks like e4 is a blender but really
black has just no move like what can
black even do
ah there's just nothing really and
eventually he'll play rook b7 jack
dislodge this king and start advancing
the h pawn
so
this was move 46 actually
so e4 was played and then he takes this
pawn rook b6 rook b4 sorry
and here i find that report played a
really nice finish to this game because
it would be
i feel like it would be very very
easy to kind of get lazy in a position
like this and sometimes that's how you
blow it but i think rapport
was
um
very very thorough uh he could have
checked on on b7 but i think he wants to
rook on b8 so that his pawn can be
escorted at some point
uh but rook b7 check was of course
possible as well i don't think it's bad
or anything keep in mind especially when
you look at the
you know the later part of a game like
this like often you can win in many ways
it's not like their way is the only way
it's it's more important that you find
you calculate it and you make sure
you're being thorough
uh maybe it would be better i don't know
that you have to pitch your pun but
something like rook here
i'm suspecting he didn't like check and
then some kind of just you know
pushing of this pun but i don't know i
mean probably he didn't have to do that
he didn't have to play e4 but
at this point though
it shouldn't matter too much like this
is just too many pass pawns to deal with
but any case this was the moment
knight takes f6 is is a bit much
probably right like takes takes
g5 maybe you're winning here but i feel
like this is
maybe not necessary
um
it might be winning though like the
pawns are just so annoying to defend
against
g5 is possible i like what he did uh
quite a bit though he played the move b6
so this had to be very well calculated
so if rook takes b6 the idea is he
simply trades in place here and this
pawn is just not stoppable
and if knight takes b6 he plays knight
takes f6 your idea
and this is very very strong because
he's pinned now this is the difference
because he's pinned black can do nothing
so you can just do this and this pawn
just like if king here you just play
here and this pawn just marches up the
board
and because of this pin you really are
pretty you're just completely helpless
so in my opinion this is a better
version of knight xf6
and if rook takes e4
he plays b7 rook b4 and then you've seen
this rook end game trick this knight is
actually irrelevant here you play here
or rook g8s and then after takes you
check and win this rook
so kind of a normal rook ending trick
but this b6 move it kind of it hangs
three two things right like these are
all moves which take pieces
but they all fail so just because he's
up a pawn and because the game is
nearing its end sort of
he still is very very careful and
calculates very accurately so fidosev
played f5 which is a fun move
but it doesn't really help after takes
takes
b7 knight f6 he finished it off with
kind of a nice move rook d8 making sure
the knight cannot get to d7
and black resigned because he's gonna
just queen next and there's nothing
really to do it to to do about it
so overall like a really fun game and at
the end very well played too like this
this technique
i fast forwarded it to make sure i had a
little bit of time but there was so many
like little details in this that were
very nice but overall just a really nice
game
a great illustration of king activity
and also just the amount of tactical
resources that are possible in an
endgame
because both sides as you saw had so
many tactics and
it's easy to get complacent when it's
the end game but i would say
you know a lot of my favorite games are
where it's an end game but there's crazy
tactics and there's still ways to try to
mate your opponent and trying to
checkmate in the end game is
literally one of my favorite things in
chess so
any game where that happens i feel like
i have to go over it
so
that is it for me tonight i hope you
guys enjoyed this game i will be back
on thursday evening doing
prepare like a gm i think the lecture is
i should probably know by now
but uh it's basically a lecture on
preparation so hopefully i'll have
another game for you guys then
and uh so join me on thursday night and
that will probably be my last lecture
for you guys so
uh i think thanks again for joining me
and i will see you guys hopefully on
thursday
[Music]
you